John after two seasons of working with
Jennifer Coolidge bring your assistant
to a vacation with your husband it's not
like she's gonna be in our bed and stuff
what's something that fans would be
surprised to know about Jennifer
I I I uh where do I start
uh you know here you have the ultimate
protagonist Jennifer can pretty much do
anything and you're on her side right
and it's kind of that way in life I'd
have to say you know you just um wildly
intelligent uh very witty and all those
wonderful things but she's um she's a
just a very warm
optimistic that's always saying it the
difference between her and Tonya she's
totally optimistic she has a has a has a
love of
Humanity love of Life Love of Animals
you have a job right yeah your work
everybody has been gushing about you all
Jennifer
um they look up to you how does that
make you feel well it's probably because
I'm the oldest
no because you're a legend that's why
you're a legend you're a legend icon
don't you want to know how I feel about
John of course that's exactly where I
was going and by the way he kept you
pretty safe on that Vespa I gotta say
yes right yes yeah what was it like
working with Tron well I've always
admired John because he was you know
Uncle Rico and uh in Napoleon Dynamic so
when's Grandma coming back I don't know
I'm not sure
you don't have to stay here with us
we're not babies
talk to your Auntie Carolyn and he's
sort of like he'll he you know we'll
never forget that and anything but yeah
I'm fine like him to be the reason why
he was
uh cast as sort of this weird man
because he is I do find John Rather
Sinister in real life is that right
um no no but I do feel that no John is
um Thomas mysterious in with I think
what makes me most mysterious is his
knowledge of everything you know have
you ever met someone like that that
knows about everything it's almost like
they go to bed with like four
encyclopedia books and then speed read
all of them I'm friends with dumb people
I don't I can't relate I can't relate
jobs I would be your friend I'm winning
dumb come out dumb too it don't matter
no you really do you I mean you can he
can talk about like you know how you can
take a boat propeller and I know
question there's a big difference
between knowing and asking will come in
handy you know the knowledge no if
you're gonna get on if you were gonna go
on a trip and it was gonna be a
dangerous trip and you had to do you
know so you have you would have to know
sort of how to rig complicated things
better I think John might be the one I
love it I love it we're gonna have to go
on vacation together sir I've been
thinking a pinch there you go that much
but I whether or not it's successful I'd
probably be the first to get you all
killed I don't know what's going on with
Greg but I think it's both I think he's
having an affair amazing you are the
only two that return from the first
season to season two of White Lotus I'm
curious how does shooting this season
compare to the last because the last
year you're dealing with some covet
things right good observation it's tough
I mean we we've got to be free this time
so did it feel like it did it feel like
a vacation then as you were filming this
oh my god dude
to be in Sicily it was it was incredible
yeah and uh I mean I had a I did it felt
like that for me because I I was kind of
more front loaded in the shooting
schedule so I a lot of the stuff I had
to do later got out of the way you got
it was it was gonna be way down the road
so I had this big space in the middle
you had a lot of work on this one you
had an inordinate amount of work you
were I felt so bad for her no it's all
right
get the pasta in yeah we got some pasta
very glamorous yeah we met some cats yes
we no we met some really cool people we
met some amazing Italians and yes you
know Sabrina told me that you also got
to have some dinners with her we went to
go shopping together we had romantic
dinners me and her but like she
organized a a party for me on my
wrapping day yeah she called them she
described them as romantic how would you
describe them well
not truly Italian no truly no yeah well
Sabrina had a birthday in Italy and she
put together this big dinner and um it
was it was one of the it was probably
one of the highlights of the whole trip
it was amazing she put it all of us
around this big table and um and
everyone had to give a speech is that
right and give a speech about and say
something yeah I mean or she oh she used
to talk about us yeah and it was I have
to say it was it was like one of the
funniest riveting things and it was it
was I don't know if it was romance I
don't know if what we were all gonna
make out with each other but it was sure
Murray shared an amazing dance in front
of all of us okay so remember there was
a long they danced and we all just were
at the table we don't have time for that
channel
I will say those two are they have a lot
of Swag to them a lot of Personality oh
yeah I can only imagine how fun it was
oh yeah yeah
[Music]